hey everyone what's up I'm Ilana welcome
my channel and today I'm taking my dog
on an adventure are you ready to tell
her she's gonna be so excited
hey Chelsea Chelsea turn the car for a
drive do you want to go in the car I
don't understand do you want to just do
it good you know I'm starting to think
she might want to so today is my last
day working at the company that I
currently work for which is real feed I
write Hurst and produce a video game
show and I thought that I would bring
Chelsea with me hey chels you have fun
are you having fun yeah you what it's
gonna be all these people ahead of me
and all of this space for her to run
around and you know maybe having her in
the studio with all the cables and these
cameras and the lights and stuff isn't
the best idea but we go through the
McDonald's drive-through so I can get
coffee but today I'm gonna buy a Chelsea
six Nuggets best day of her life she
doesn't even know it yet I think right
now people hi can I please get a small
vanilla latte with skim milk and six
Nuggets
Thank You happiness take it the whole
thing Oh what are you good
what's that what do you want you tell
that oh yeah we have arrived at the
destination my hair is progressively
getting more and more frizzy throughout
the course of this video because it's so
freaking humid in Brisbane right now so
that means first step is get inside and
get little puffy some water you know she
has no idea what she is
you can tell look look how curious she
walks
I don't think dogs have those kinds of
facial expressions but she is excited
and we're gonna get us something to
drink
the Nuggets have been destroyed and also
that was his bag I had that had a shirt
in it she somehow pulled the shut out
and got nugget all over it and I need to
return that shirt the show is on the
different side of the car how did she
even do that you just are you ready to
get out of the car I know you're pretty
hot no no you pretty what we'll get you
some water
it'll be great oh my god my life is so
exciting I'm really worried that I'm
gonna drop the camera cuz she's gonna
like pull it then it's gonna fall out of
my hand but she seems pretty stoked so
far hey are you doing what is that it's
a doll I'm feeling admit hey little Jose
what is everything it's all new and
exciting here you go say hi to everyone
excited chief Chelsea yeah I don't jump
on the table
don't jump let me take you public good
obsessed but keep going what's up you
pay Internet we now have my dog in front
of a green screen do with this what you
will get smells on that carpet is it
good so much excitement in you what's
all this stuff
who is it all I'm Alana Oh
he's dependent on your special all right
do you have fun chels
did you have fun
okay so that is walk wrapped up Chelsea
is very hot she drank so much water just
then I'm not gonna lie it's really hot
in Brisbane today but to say goodbye
they also got me some red wine and a cod
so that's super lovely good food
accomplished last night no trust me the
wine is not for you Chelsea oh my god I
can't take you anywhere
I'll take my little puppy home and give
her even more water because seriously
she really drink some love what up I
wanna thank you guys for watching this
silly little vlog that I'm sure I will
also look back on very funny
and I will see you guys next time bye